coffee on a Tuesday and block 35 so
there's a way to use hashtags to
categorize tweets or messages so that
they show up more easily in searches but
I don't ever use hashtags like that
there are amazing political consequences
to hashtags fast and easy ways to
communicate to find information on a
particular subject or event like a riot
or a revolution but I don't ever use
hashtags like that either the hashtag
was thriving when I came to it people
were already using it for all those
democratizing reasons I just mentioned
as a way of networking or advocating but
the networking function of hashtags
never really interested me but I noticed
that people were using hashtags in other
ways to to express sarcasm or wit or
inner monologue or self deprecation and
I thought I can get into that the first
hashtag I ever used was on an Instagram
photo I took in LA of a man who is
dressed up as a yellow transformer who
was you know done with his day just
walking home from work in his custom my
caption was melancholy transformer
hashtag save yourself so at the expense
of murdering comedy by analyzing it I
was making a joke here about a man whose
job seemed to be to dress up in a bulky
Transformers costume and walk around the
streets of LA and he didn't seem too
happy about and hashtag save yourself is
just a way of saying you can do better
than this just for a moment let's
disregard all the ridiculous assumptions
I'm making about this guy's life who I
know nothing about who very well might
look is Jim a very well just have gotten
back from transformers who very well
might have a perfectly normal fetish for
dressing up as bubble who may very well
be a transforming Android now I could
have just said save yourself no hashtag
and the message I was trying to convey
about this guy's life would have gotten
across what I'm interested in is whether
or not the addition of a hashtag has any
literary value to the sentiment and I
think it does I was mocking but at the
same time borrowing the intended
function of hashtags as a means to
connect our expression in order to add a
layer of subtext to the comic instead of
just telling this guy to get a life I
was making like the hashtag save
yourself grouping all right
existed that it was trending people were
adding to it as a way to infer that this
ridiculous thing is only one example of
millions of similarly ridiculous things
maybe even a ridiculous thing that you
with the hashtag you invoke the
community even when the community isn't
there of course I wasn't thinking this
out as I did it and the only way that I
learned the literary way of using
hashtags is by seeing other people do it
first and there are many other ways to
use hashtags dramatically to express
self deprecation or inner monologue or
insecurity I find it fascinating that we
can't help but repurpose everything we
see into stories even metadata Shaw
metadata and your functions we will take
your metadata and make it into drama we
are an expressive race to say the least
and it's no surprise to me that Twitter
caught on like it did it's no surprise
the effect it's already had on the world
and it's no surprise that we figured out
how to make little messages into big
messages without ever changing the
character count hey everyone and screen
heaven here so I want to let you know
that we did a story last week on lean
forward about the one-year anniversary
of Occupy Wall Street which I've put on
my facebook page and I'll put the link
in the doobly-doo so from now on that's
where I'm going to put the links to
videos or stories that I do on MSNBC
besides that check out fifty two books
in two weeks don't forget to follow me
on tumblr there and hash tag goodbye